we're going to get started thank you all
for coming in alternate borrower thank
you I think there was thank you this
very special college application I want
to thank a few people as possible first
in the foremost kyra scared us early
socialization sizes the art director of
the seraphic international editions of
politics I think also in economic
centers of the street apartment horse
neighs goes to the highest college for
hosting us including
by attritional injected speeding also
affect the university lecture series and
the humanities scholar and the scholars
program mother which helped to
co-sponsor danke an acknowledge dr. Tim
Haggerty director the many scholars
program thank you all for Italy as
possible our team was born in 1948 i was
born in 1947
you
Dean was raised in East Hampton on the
history of Long Island the hero city
after attending Yale we got patched
agreed to receive this repertory at
color else technology medicine
university were in his place to discover
within the open and family ever practice
in Vermont surprisingly it wasn't health
care reform that your daughter Dean into
politics rather was proposed kind of
leading development and the shores of
Lake Champlain and indeed throughout his
public career he's good a strong voice
navigant or manage growth
responsibilities pain after serving two
terms and provides customer ratings dr.
Dean is elected lieutenant governor and
then serve six to two year terms as
governor of vermont in 1991 to see 2003
making him the second longest serving
governor in the state's history despite
being the only state of the union that
does not constitutionally man named
balanced budget during governor Dean's
tenure harmonica automotive its
outstanding debt Alice tits watching 11
times in lower income taxes twice I'm
checking on that here
Governor David also focuses attention
for health care issues resulting a
significant drop in rate of uninsured in
his state during his administration I'd
like to have a personal observation that
to me I've always been impressed by the
great range of knowledge he's displayed
on a public policy issues I recall
earlier visit he made throughout campus
we were just chatting about this and he
came here to a given key on a dress and
a confidence about cybersecurity I think
he weren't sharing an information
technology committee for the National
Governors Association that time it was
very impressive indeed rhinology
displayed outside of security which you
nut I didn't expect the sitting governor
know so much up and I think he impressed
very much the techies they were sitting
in an audience I be characterized as a
liberal preventer Dean's record defies
easy categorization while his garter the
side of the patience perseverance
legislation law at the same time is also
endorsed by the National Rifle
Association sometimes during his tenure
was covered covered at amedisys can see
que se for presidency in 2003 as actual
emphasized health care and fiscal
responsibility as well as champion
esperance home raised his campaign is
the first distantly use the internet
strategy which of course was very
rapidly copied by his opponents has
become a standard part of our politics
cover Dean found the group democracy for
america in 2004 in order to use internet
based organization to support an occupy
the candidates use a play in the chair
of the Democratic National Committee in
2005 rather catch train a few swing
states is so-called 50-state strategy
was committed to winning elections and
early level across the country and is
credited and carved for results of the
2006 election which brought Democratic
majorities developed the house and the
Senate after 30 years in politics cover
Dean left public service in 2009 is now
pretty frequently seen commentator and
contributor to cmec financial news
network and MSNBC please join me in
welcoming back another Howard
Thank You mr. president he's got kind of
nice ring to it then I'm going to talk
about the health of our nation but it's
not like going to be mostly about health
care but hopefully the majority of this
hour is going to be yours to combat
comments and questions rather than my
just give a lecture I will just say one
thing you know that was a very nice bio
and there was only one little thing that
was not right I always make these
Corrections I was actually not appointed
as the DNC chair if that was an
appointed position I would never would
have been appointed because nobody
inside the beltway wanted me but
fortunately there 477 447 votes and 350
of them are outside the Beltway it was
an election much to the chagrin of all
the Democratic insiders who didn't like
the 50-state strategy or anything else
that was good for them I want to this is
actually the first time I've ever given
the talk that i'm about to give and so
bear with me it is not meant as a
partisan talk although i suspect that
the partisan leanings of my own partisan
leanings are shared by a lot of you it's
not met as a partisan talk if when i
give this talk and I've given little
pieces of it before Republicans react to
it strongly is it it's not meant to do
that it's meant to be thoughtful and I
want you to bear with me the first thing
I before I get into this is I'm talking
about the long-term health of our
country I'm not talking about the
short-term economic downturn I'm not
talking about the fact that we're in
Iraq in Afghanistan and you know these
things have come and gone were a very
strong country I'm not even talking
about our economy there's a great I
served I worked for a couple years on
Wall Street before I went to night
school and got myself in a medical
school years ago and there was a saying
then that I think is true today as it
was that is don't bet against the United
States don't bet against the United
States economy it's an enormous very
vibrant economy so I want to start by
saying that but there are some very
serious problems that we're facing that
transcend the fights every day about how
we're going to spend are we going to cut
the deficit and all that kind of stuff
that is mostly noise on cable television
in Washington and here's what I worry
about a lot and you should too and then
at this you'll be happy to know this
talk ends with good news which is the
news that you're going to be in charge
of this country soon and that's going to
be a big improvement because I think our
generation is about done Hillary Clinton
talked a few years ago and was made fun
of of course about you some of you may
remember this a vast right-wing
conspiracy and she was only wrong in one
way it's not a conspiracy when you do
things in the open there's nothing that
you can't call it a conspiracy but going
back over and I'm not we're not talking
about crackpots in the john birch
society people like that although they
seem to be in the ascendancy now that's
a relevant temporary phenomenon in the
history of the country i mean that's
going on before father Coughlin you may
have some of you students of history in
the 1930s a priest was actually I think
kicked out of the church but because he
was embracing racist ideas and so forth
in this very popular radio show the rush
limbaugh of his day the know-nothings an
anti-catholic anti-immigrant group
before the Civil War who was crusading
against immigrants that weren't white
anglo-saxon Protestants from Europe so
there's a long history of all these
kinds of illnesses that we see today
going back in our country a long way if
you have a democracy and if you have a
Jeffersonian democracy you can't avoid
populism Andrew Jackson the famous story
but when he became inaugurated and
20,000 people walked in there hobnail
boots through the White House and
wrecked half the the carpets and so
forth and so on so those things you have
to sort out differently because those
things come and go in cycles and these
things are coming and they'll go to some
of this talk but this notion of the
right-wing desire to run things
differently is threatened to the country
and it comes in a couple of
forms the first that i worry about
deeply is the concerted effort to put
right-wing ideologues on the bench of
the United States we have today Supreme
Court which in my opinion is composed of
four relatively moderate jurists for
right-wing ideologues and one
conservative being Anthony Kennedy that
is deeply troubling the two court cases
which in my opinion are two of the worst
court cases in the very long history of
the United States and on par with the
Dred Scott decision in fact the Dred
Scott decision was actually more based
on constitutional law than the two court
cases I'm about to mention because in
fact in the Constitution it did count
african-american slaves as three
quarters of a white person the two court
cases that this Court has decided not
they're not the Roberts Court but
Rehnquist before him where Bush versus
Gore and citizens united now we're not
talking about conservative versus
liberal here we're not talking about a
case where the labor unions were decided
that it couldn't have as much power or
that it wasn't as easy to vote as it
should be we're not talking about an
argument between Democrats and
Republicans we are talking about for
political purposes undermining the
Constitution of the United States there
is nowhere in the Constitution of the
United States where it says a
corporation is a person that was an
invented right that was invented by the
Supreme Court of the United States there
is nowhere in the embarrassment of Bush
versus Gore which is really actually a
worse decision than citizens united from
a legal point of view in my opinion and
I'm not a lawyer so if there are some
here you're let's have a debate about
this the embarrassment of Bush versus
Gore was the last sentence of the
decision said this decision shall not be
used as precedent in any future case if
you're a jurist and you put that in your
decision you are essentially saying we
are making this up for the purposes of
this election that is not the role of
the Supreme Court of the United
there is a mechanism there was a
mechanism in the Constitution to resolve
the Bush versus Gore election at the end
of the day Congress becomes the judge
and each delegation votes individually
on who gets their votes that's not what
they did they start with it remember
what that Court decision did it stopped
the votes from being counted from being
recounted in Florida so you had the
highest court in the in the united
states of america the leading democracy
in the world saying we are not going to
count the votes anymore that is a deeply
disturbing precedent and again this is
not about a court case about the death
penalty or a court case about gun rights
or these things that will these things
change they go back and forth the courts
are susceptible to some public opinion
hopefully not nearly as much as the
other political branches are this was a
core undermining of the democratic
process I don't know what the motives
were of course we can all suspect what
you know but given the allegiances of
the judges and how they got to power the
ones that made this decision it was a
five-to-four decision when Richard
Nixon's case about whether the tapes
that were taken in the White House
during the Watergate era went to the
court a group of nine justices who had
been appointed by both Democrats and
Republicans decided nine to nothing that
those tapes had to be made public nine
to nothing there was no Democrat
Republican split on that court this was
a five-to-four decision it showed a
gross failure on the part of the chief
justice because most chief justice is
here to Ford don't make Herto for had
not made groundbreaking enormous
decisions of this magnitude with a
five-to-four decision and it showed a
contempt for the law and more
importantly a contempt for the American
voter which is what I think the core
issue is in the soap quote unquote vast
ring wing vast right-wing capacity
conspiracy not that the right wing is
bad or the left wing is bad I grew up in
an era when the left wing was as awful
as the right wing is today they were
burning up
down buildings they were I mean there
cause may have been a cause that I was
sympathetic with we shouldn't be in
Vietnam they were doing appalling things
that he had no business doing just as
the right is doing today but is a what
those two court cases are incredibly
dangerous because it means the equation
of the the refusal to continue with a
vote recount so we can actually know
what the voters really wanted is a core
attack on democracy the core value of
this incredible country that we're in
and the notion that free speech is not
only is not only epitomized by money and
equivalent to money that is so therefore
the implication is the more money you
have the more free speech you get that's
bad enough the idea of the corporation
suddenly inherited the rights of
individuals who vote and pay taxes in
the United States of America and they
are now classified as people with all
the inalienable rights of under the
Declaration of Independence that people
had is a attack on the very values that
America was founded on 235 years ago so
these were two so this this federal
judiciary has been poisoned in many ways
by things like the federalist society
the federalist society was not put
together as a social club for the
betterment of Justices anderous it was
put together as an antidote today what
they felt was a liberal bias on the part
of the relatively elite lawyers who
ended up in the Supreme Court and in the
federal bench the problem is unlike the
American Bar Association and the other
non partisan bar and lawyers or legal
organizations there was a political bent
to this and it got to be when you went
before the president to get yourself
appointed to the bench if it was a
republican president you'd better be a
member of the federalist society is a
very dangerous precedent that is a long
term problem for the united states that
transcends the arguments that we see
today in Washington about whether the
Tea Party
going to cut the budget and where
they're going to cut it the second
problem is the degradation of our news
media now I think there may be a
solution to some of these things but
it's a serious problem and we'll start
with Fox because that's the easy one
there's a difference between Fox and
MSNBC they're both biased the New York
Times is biased the wall street journal
is biased the north New York Post is
biased newspapers have bias the
Pittsburgh Post is certainly BIOS that
the tribute I forgot which one is the
right which one's the right-wing paper
here okay but but they're both biased
you can't pick up any paper without the
personal opinions of the of the reporter
whether it's on the left or the right
getting into the article it's true I go
read the New York Times you can do i
think the New York Times agrees with me
most of the time so I of course I think
think they're great right but if you
read this whatever the story is this I'm
sure there's some political story on the
front page of the New York Times today
and by the third or fourth paragraph the
the reporter is ushering in their own
opinion bias is not the problem it's
something that makes us mad but it's not
the problem it's when you become a
propaganda outlet what Fox News is not
says is often not true and they know
it's not true and they say it anyway it
is not a news organization is a very
expensive incredibly well funded
right-wing propaganda organization the
definition of propaganda is you take
something with a small kernel of truth
to it you add you twist and you make it
into the story the death panels is a
perfect example the death panels you
remember the phrase let me tell you
about the death panels that were in the
health care bill in the Congress before
George Bush left office that was a
Republican Congress Charles Grassley is
senator from Iowa is the chairman of the
Senate health education welfare
committee there was a call for a
Medicare overhaul and needed some things
needed to be reauthorized in that pant
in that Medicare overhaul Charles
Grassley
had inserted into the bill something
that said that seniors should get
end-of-life counseling because a lot of
money was being spent at the end of life
and in many cases seniors were not being
afforded the opportunity to make life
ending the choices I'm not we're not
talking about terminating your life or
euthanasia but the idea was that you
should give seniors more control over
something that's incredibly important to
us which is not just what your life is
like at the beginning in the middle but
what it's like at the end so this was
something with bipartisan everybody
support it's a sensible thing to do you
should be able to you should pay this
the internist or the primary care
provider for sitting down and speaking
to the senior patient about end-of-life
issues it was passed nobody said
anything about it when the health care
bill was being written now under
democratic management the committee that
was drafting the health care bill took
the language from Charles Grassley and
put it in their bill because they
thought and the black counseling was a
good idea and that should be in the
health care reform it shouldn't just be
available to people on Medicare should
be well available to everybody that
became the death panel it was written by
a Republican senator cheering when he
shared his committee it was a smart idea
the vast majority of Americans believe
it's a good idea that seniors and their
doctors should be encouraged to talk
about end-of-life issues and I forgive
Sarah Palin for doing this I mean I
don't think she's going to be present
the United States and politicians can
say things and anybody can say anything
they want but I don't forgive a supposed
news organization who put that out every
single day knowing it was a lie there
was a really interesting poll at the end
of the Bush era towards the end of the
Bush era the second Bush you write that
showed that sixty-five percent of people
who watched Fox believed that Saddam
Hussein had something to do with Al
Qaeda's attack on the world trade
centers thirteen percent of NPR viewers
listeners believe that the President of
the United States George Walker Bush was
asked whether that was true or not and
he said no Saddam Hussein had nothing to
do with the attack in the World Trade
Centers the reason that sixty-five
percent of the people who viewed Fox and
got their news from Fox believed that
was not because they were dumb because
they were lied to every single day on
virtually every program on Fox News I
think we've crossed a line here that has
redefined the media and it's not just
Fox I pick on Fox because they're the
best funded and because they have a
clear mission I mean when the this is
not thats another thing that fox has
done which i've never seen done before
they gave a million dollars to the
democrat the Republican Governors
Association how can you pretend to be a
news organization while you're funding a
political party so it's a different way
we haven't done this before it does
happen in Europe political parties have
their own newspapers people choose to
read them they and in this country
people who listen to fox aren't all no
Republican stalwarts they'd like listen
to fox as they prefer to be angry at the
left just like we listen to NBC MSNBC
because we like what they're telling us
the truth is the facts under MSNBC or
true and when they're not true I mean
you may not like the spin you may not
like the kind of nasty smarmy stuff that
that people say about other people
they're not nice i'm saying i'm on i go
in those shows sometimes they're usually
nice to me but they go on because i'm
not nice to the republicans but if they
make a mistake and they get the facts
wrong they correct it the next day so
that's number one part that's not the
biggest problem the fact that we have a
propaganda outlet that most people think
is a news outlet the biggest problem is
the corporatization of the American news
media and that can't be fixed and it's
not going to be fixed and here's what
the problem is i am not a conspiracy
theorist i do not believe that
corporations call up the news the
General Electric used to call up Brian
Williams say you can't run that store
because this is our product that blew up
in the desert and killed six people and
you know we can't have that story I
don't think they do that maybe they do
it once in a great while and I think
most the time they try it doesn't work
the news man says I really can't work
for you under those circumstances I'm
not gonna why is it dangerous to have a
corporatized news media because the news
has become a profit Center and because
if it doesn't make money then it gets
cut back so what I was growing up there
were three news channels ABC NBC and CBS
they had the three most respected people
in America giving the news Howard k
smith john chancellor and Walter
Cronkite and they all lost money that's
what they all had in common those three
things they all lost money CBS didn't
care they had the biggest show they used
that show in Walter Cronkite to lead
into the price is right they made a hell
lot of money advertising on the price is
right and whatever came before the CBS
news today General Electric doesn't care
i'm not picking a general i think
general x is a great company but general
electric or Viacom or disney jones ABC
they don't care about the news media or
Brian Williams or whoever Katie Couric
they want to know if you made money and
if you didn't make money you're going to
get fired if you're the anchor because
your news isn't exciting enough and your
staffs going to have the hell cut out of
it until you show a profit two things
happen as a result one is you don't get
the kind of coverage you need that is
they can't have 20 correspondents all
over the world maybe they get cut down
they can only have five and so they
start making compromising you start not
getting not hearing about things that
you probably should be hearing about and
they cut and they cut and they cut until
they can make money there's another
thing that's worse this is that what
they say about local news and you'll
probably I'm sure this has got to be as
true in Pittsburgh visit is true and
everyplace else I've been if it bleeds
it leads there is a ghoulish part of
human psyche including in all of us even
though we're educated University
but we like to believe this isn't true i
can show you lots of polling data to
show that it is true it's there is a
ghoulish sided all of us that where we
kind of want to hear these horrible
things maybe to remind us that it's
somebody else it's not happening to us
whatever the reason is why gossip as a--
has a market even among well-educated
people it is the lowest common
denominator the great thing about Walter
Cronkite and John count that Chancellor
and all those folks is they had to eat
eat your peas mentality John Edwards
love child would never got on the
network's because it wasn't essential to
understanding how to defend the United
States or how to balance the budget or
where where the crew crucial decision
points were about who was deciding what
in the State Capitol in Washington or in
a foreign country it would never have
gotten on the evening news it leads now
why because it excites our prairie and
interest so the news is to baste itself
and cut its back its ability to do even
the little decent job that it does now
are these I happen to like Brian
Williams as a person we love Katie Kirk
that's who we happen to watch because I
think her tone is more uplifting and
she's likely to have a more balanced
approach to things but these programs
are shadows of their former selves and I
think the American people are not being
well served by a media that seeks the
lowest common denominator because it's
entirely profit based so that is that is
the that's a core institution look I'm a
professional media hater right I'm a
politician I never got a break from the
medium The Scream speech right they
dress it all up anybody in the room at
the squeeze for anybody was in Iowa at
The Scream speech nobody here okay well
it was very different it didn't quite
sound the way it did by the time Fox got
done with it so I have every reason to
dislike them and i can tell you great
fun horror stories maybe the Q&A period
i will but the truth is the media
without a media we can't have a free
country the media is what makes this
country work in the sense that it stops
politicians from becoming clep the
crooks everybody thinks all politicians
are crooks believe me ninety percent of
them actually
at all and probably never done anything
that is thoroughly dishonest why is that
because a fair number of know if they do
it will get on the front page of the
local paper and they'll be in trouble
the media is an essential institution
for the strength of a democracy in our
media is very very weak and it is a
Norma's long-term problem for the
country finally and in some ways this is
the biggest problem of all capitalism is
headed for failure in this country and
the reason capitalism is headed for
failure in this country is because the
capitalists are killing capitalism what
most people in the business and business
world have understood for a long time is
that regulation is essential for
capitalism too much regulation does
stifle jobs I don't quarrel with that
but having no regulation which is the
aim of the far right essentially is like
playing football without a referee at
all people get hurt and exactly the
phenomenon is now happening in this
country begins to happen which is that
the eighty percent of average wage
earners have seen no increase in their
wages here for 20 years in this country
this is not all George Bush's fault this
is both Democrats and Republicans fault
it was Bill Clinton that signed the
abolition of the glass-steagall Act
which allowed the banks that do what
they did to help get us into this
terrible mess we're in this is a
bipartisan problem that we have been so
influenced with the help of course of
the Supreme Court and things like
citizens united by the business
community that they are doing things
that are against their own interest
eighty percent of the American people
have not seen an increase in their
purchasing power for 20 years the entire
amount of growth in the economy of the
United States of America has occurred in
the top twenty percent of wage earners
the top one percent of Americans owns
twice as much of a percent as a
percentage of America
than they did 20 years ago and that of
course has to come from somebody else
and it comes from the people who art in
the top 1% now do I say this is the
left-wing socialist by the way that's
another little meat lie that the Fox
people tell of it if they knew what a
socialist was which I have every reason
to suspect they might they certainly
wouldn't call Obama a socialist do I say
this because I'm a Marxist no I am
actually a capitalist I sir have done
some time on Wall Street I believe in
the investing in the stock market and
these kinds of things I hate to see
capitalists kill themselves and that's
what they're doing because when this is
a sociological fact not a theoretical
wish when the gap between those at the
top the top twenty percent and the
bottom twenty percent gets too big
society gets unstable and that you can
go look go back and look that up for the
last 2,000 years in order to make
capitalism works everybody has to
believe it benefits them or if it
doesn't benefit them it's somehow their
fault which means you have to have a
very small percentage of the population
that isn't directly benefited by it
oddly enough this is this is what this
is what the shortsightedness of the Koch
brothers and Governor Walker in
Wisconsin is it's just so dumb I can
understand having a fight with unions
and complaining about unions I can't
figure out how you want why do you want
to get rid of them the most prosperous
time in America other than the last
couple years of Bill Clinton that was
really pop prosperous for the top 20%
but not a lot of other people was in the
50s when the unions with their most
powerful and in this town you could
leave high school with high school
education maybe not even and get
yourself a job in the steel mill and
your kids could go to college and while
the Ford family might have a palatial
estate on the lake of lake on the shores
of Lake Michigan the guys that worked in
the plant could still rent a little
colic cottage for a couple of weeks a
year and take their kids there and they
that was fine with them I think those
robber barons like the Koch brothers are
putting all this money into changing
America they don't understand working
people aren't envious of the Koch
brothers
all they want is to make sure the system
is fair this is not about everybody has
the same amount of money the average
person labour Union doesn't want what
the Koch brothers have they just want to
make sure that if they work hard they
get a fair deal and that is being badly
eroded and it's not just being eroded in
terms of numbers I gave you the average
American is beginning to believe that
the system doesn't work for him anymore
that is a very dangerous place for
America to be headed and it needs to be
changed and it doesn't necessarily need
to be changed by going back to the way
the old Democrats used to do it with a
lot of too much spending it a lot of
mindless regulation but we have got to
get rid of this notion that it's us
against them either from the rich folks
like the Koch brothers who think that
for whatever reason they're entitled to
have everything they want spent as much
money as they can to victimize others or
from the kind of the old left-wing the
labor movement who thought that
everybody who had money was evil we are
all in this together and the people that
have risen to the top and the Republican
Party right now either are afraid to
confront what they know is true which is
that those folks are extremists and
shouldn't be allowed to push this kind
of policy in their party or they believe
it they believe that somehow they are
entitled to something that nobody else
is entitled to by virtue of the fact
that they have a lot of money which they
i might add they inherited so this isn't
about who works harder than who it's not
about rich people being bad it's about
balance and fairness in a society in a
place where everybody feels that if they
work hard they can prosper that is the
core of the American agreement for the
first time I think in our history the
American Dream is in trouble it's been
in trouble before but it's been cyclical
and we've learned from it the Gilded Age
is the great before it right before the
Great Depression was a time but we learn
from that and now we have worker
protections many of them because we had
a strong labor movement can you make the
case that labor movements did cause
sclerosis of the economy yes you
certainly can too many work rules you
those kinds of things yes you can make
those cases but those things are best
solver the negotiating table and not by
taking away rights of working people
that have helped to balance the system
when it was badly out of balance when we
hit the depression so I what I want to
leave you with however is the good news
the good news is is the new generation
here that has is changing everything I
talked to a lot of gay and lesbian
groups because as the president said I
was the first person ever to sign a
civil unions bill in this country and
they're usually in despair because of
Don't Ask Don't Tell and discrimination
and votes like the one in California
which for proposition 8 which undid
their right to marry after they had it
and I said why let's look at the
slightly longer term here when George
Bush it was obviously arguably the most
conservative president we've had since
calvin coolidge came into the White
House there was one state in the country
with marriage equality which is mine
when he left the White House there were
nine why is that you had this
conservative and 46 to those eight years
that president bush was in office the
house of the Senate and the White House
were all controlled by the Republicans
the Conservative Party how could this be
because change doesn't come from the top
it comes from the ground up it's what
you do at the local level in what you
believe in your personal lives and how
you act on that change in your personal
life that ultimately makes the
difference if you don't believe me look
what happened in Tucker your square not
so long ago this generation is an
extraordinary generation with values
that are in some ways similar to ours
but in many other ways not the first
thing about it is you are not tolerant
you are inclusive the Republicans
actually have figured out that they have
a problem that this because I actually
do have friends that are Republican
because they were operatives against me
and now they're our friends because
we're all retired and you know we can
sit around telling war stories but they
know they have a big problem because in
your generation no my generation my end
of the spectrum was very Pro civil
rights and we all did what we could and
so forth and so on and things changed a
lot
a whole lot but we didn't grow up with
people who are different than we were we
grew up in her own silos and we happen
to work with each other but not
necessarily live with each other today
people in your generation everybody has
friends of different races ethnicities
of languages and ethnic backgrounds and
sexual orientation you all date each
other so you can't be a gay bashing
party you can't be an immigrant bashing
party you can't be a Muslim bashing
party and get anybody whose votes who's
under the age of 35 years old because
you're whacking their friends your
generation is more conservative fiscally
certainly than the left wing of the
Democratic Party much more conservative
particularly after what you've been
through trying to get a job when you
graduate from even a place like Carnegie
Mellon and not so easy my daughter just
graduated from one of the best law
schools in America and she had a hard
time she want to be a public defender
took her a long time to get a job that
she wouldn't have taken such a long time
getting had it been five years ago so it
is much tougher they could get you on
fiscally conservative grounds but
they're never going to get you as long
as they're bashing your friends so they
got to get through that secondly your
generation essentially doesn't really
care much about politics I don't mean in
a bad way you're not indifferent you
elected Barack Obama people who elected
Barack Obama were under 35 years old the
first election in my lifetime were more
people under 35 voted than who are over
35 never happened my lifetime before you
elected Barack Obama why cuz he looks
like you he's multicultural so was your
generation the first multicultural
generation the history of the United
States of America we've been a
multicultural country for a long time
but this is a multicultural generation
but I'm not sure that that's the kind of
thing we might have done you know we
believe that we're going to change the
system I don't think a lot of you care
about changing the system you liked
Obama because he was your generations
president but my experience with your
generations when you want to change them
that you just go on the net and find 100
other people just like you and then you
put together a project
you do it and you don't go to City Hall
and you know petition the Congress of
the United States you just do it when I
was not very long ago actually charter
schools were creation of the right
charter schools were created originally
to maintain segregation in the south to
avoid the anti-discrimination stuff that
was coming out of the courts and then to
attack the teachers unions today charter
schools are mainstream started by people
your age who'd gone to places like Teach
for America and are making the beginning
to make a huge difference in the inner
cities why because people like you have
adopted them and it has nothing to do
with fact I actually do a little work
for a charter school that's run by the
united federation of teachers in east
new york we don't care what the ideology
is you want these kids to have an
education and stop talking about it for
40 years and do something about it
that's what your generation is alright
thank you we appreciate the audiology we
appreciate the talk now let's get down
to work so that's a big plus secondly
the free market actually does work and
guess what it works in information as
well so if you don't want to believe all
that horse manure on cable television
where Fox guess what you just go on the
net and you get your news from the net
by the time oh gosh it's going to be so
soon now I don't know exactly when there
won't be any television anymore because
you're just going to hook up your modem
put the big wide screen computer you'll
have 20,000 football games and whatever
you can see or anything else you want to
see and I don't know how these
television stations people are going to
stay in business anymore because why
would you bother I mean you could just
get it on your computer and that'll be
the evening news or you won't bother
with evenings you'll just follow the
blog now the problem with the blocks of
course is even more misinformation on
there than there is in Fox and that's
saying something so you know the liberal
arts educators and I was you know
victimized by them to you know always
used to tell us in social studies class
that we were not trying to tell you what
to think we're trying to teach you how
to think well now we're going to find
out if that works or not because you're
going to be exposed to every kind of
nonsense that you have seen I think
imagine the internet and you're gonna
have to decide based on what you know
and what makes sense into Europe because
of your own education both in school and
experientially what you want to believe
or not
so it's I don't know how this story is
going to come out but I know that that's
the antidote to the degradation of the
media so people ask me all the time
should we have term limits you know
these horrible politicians in Washington
I say I'm absolutely against term limits
but I'll settle for a constitutional
amendment that prevents anybody over 50
from serving in the United States Senate
that will fix all the problems so the
good news is your generation is going to
do it differently the only thing I would
leave you with is this no change ever
got made without persistence there is no
such thing as and this happens all the
time and I think there's a little of
this in your generation because it's a
human trait you elect Barack Obama and
you say great now he's going to fix
everything we can go back to doing
whatever we were doing before you can't
do that you have to be in politics every
single day and I don't mean you know I
know a bunch of you I'm sure slept on
floors for 20 weeks for Obama I don't
mean that kind of politics although of
course I encourage that I mean politics
is what you do in your own community to
make things better if you're organizing
the school or your painting houses in
Mississippi that's politics it's
community organizing is what politics is
you always have to do some of that
pretty soon if some of you have already
started you're going to be out of here
you're going to have families you're
going to have jobs you you know it's
hard when you have responsibilities to
take time for politics you have to do it
it's the price of living in a democracy
and if you're not willing to pay the
price some day you're going to wake up
and there's not going to be a democracy
I used to think that democracy was the
highest evolutionary form of government
and therefore when we got there we could
worry about somebody else's democracy
you have to worry about your own
democracy and there have been some
things in this country that have been
extraordinarily disturbing that are
threatening that democracy and it's up
to you to make sure that it gets passed
on not just from us to you but from you
to your own kids thanks very much
okay tableau longer than that statement
I'll try to give short answers yes I
thank you so much for speaking with us I
thought that was a great diagnosis you
mentioned citizens united and our
ability to larkin passed in the Gilded
Age how would you assess the prospects
of performs like disclosed at work
congressional public financing and you
have any advice for campaign finance
reform as I do I have two piece of
advice first of all make sure Obama gets
reelected because he's I like very much
his two Supreme Court justices and he
gets a chance to put two or three more
on there we might actually have a court
that believes in the law and read the
Constitution timers soon secondly local
action New York City actually is going
to have an attempt to put on their
ballot they tuning up of their public
financing of campaigns Arizona not
exactly a flaming liberal state has a
pretty good campaign finance reforms
that statute this is an interesting
story because it showed you this is not
this stuff is not necessarily partisan
it that some Republicans think campaign
financing is bad for ideological reasons
in Arizona the legislature there's a one
you have to understand there's a party
that's more important than Republicans
or Democrats in every legislature in
Congress is called the incumbent party
and they don't want to get unelected no
matter who they are and they often in
California for example one of the huge
problems they have is the Republicans
the Democrats get together and draw the
district line so last year out of the
entire California Assembly there was one
district that was in play 11 Republicans
say yeah we don't mind being a minority
we like it being here Democrats said who
are we to argue and they cut their
districts up so that nobody could yes
this does not serve democracy for it so
what you can do is go to this I hate
referendum government because it's used
to take people's rights away which is
wrong but it was originally intended to
make sure the legislature didn't run
roughshod off the public so use
referendum in Arizona the public after
they getting disgusted with their
legislature put on the ballot a fairly
decent lawd until the Supreme Court
started
away at it which basically creates a
financing a public financing system that
both the current governor who's a
Republican and the previous governor was
a Democrat one under and when their
primaries under they did by referendum
the legislature tried to get it off the
ballot the unions and the Chamber of
Commerce both put money into getting rid
of it because of course they're both
special interest groups and they lost so
there's a lot of hope for local axes if
you can't do it at the statewide level
because you in one of the eastern states
which is less likely to have a
referendum government you could often do
it just for your city or for your town
I'm a huge fan of what I call Instant
Runoff voting some people call it ranked
voting and so forth why well there's two
reasons first of all of course you don't
get the spectacle in somebody winning
with forty-two percent of the vote when
68% voted against that person but it
also something that nobody understands
it makes the campaign's much more civil
they use it in San Francisco and I went
out there to help somebody because
they'd help me in my presidential
campaign and i discovered that people at
the top of the ticket were giving
fundraisers for their opponents at the
bottom of course in San Francisco's 18
people running for a city council see
and several of whom had well we won't
get into that but anyway it was San
Francisco very interesting political
culture but nobody was saying anything
bad about each other and when they did
it was about issues disagreements not
you know so-and-so is a socialist and
all this crap and why was that because
they needed the second place vote so if
you and I are running against each other
I'm trashing you in the ads guess who
your voters aren't going to vote for
under any circumstances it civilized as
campaigns and focuses them back on the
issues in a way from personals so
there's a lot of reforms like that and I
truly believe the Congress will never
pass that stuff because neither side
will want to try to give up any
advantage but it'll be done piece by
piece and like Social Security which
actually started in the in the
depression the real Depression started
in 1926 in rural States in 1929 when
Wall Street collapsed and in the late
20s Social Security came in and places
like in the Midwest because old people
were starving and it eventually
Roosevelt put it into became
no program I think if you did campaign
finance reform piece by piece locally
sit up city by city you would eventually
create an atmosphere where enough people
had to represented you in Washington
would have to vote for it wouldn't get
done but then of course you need a
Supreme Court that actually wanted to
follow the law yes yeah talk about a lot
of our problems but Indiana seats and
other if you thought either how many
concrete solutions there uks our system
with a safe box appear in the form of
the BBC and also come back out that's
what I manual because how many times i
watch any of them to be I just watched
some on youtube of what happy at Wilson
at the antidote I mean look we're not
going to we have a strong First
Amendment I think we should have a
person I think much as I think you know
the Fox groups and Murdoch's people were
bad for democracy and they should know
better but I don't quibble with their
right to say whatever they want I only
you're going to have a truth commission
because one person's truth is another's
political inconvenience so I think one
of this great things about our country
is the extraordinary and are we are an
outlier even the Europeans there you
know you can go to jail for saying there
was no such thing as the Holocaust in
Germany and people do go to jail for
saying that when I understand why they
have that law given their history but
that would not happen here the libel
laws in Britain you know if you say
something terrible about somebody
they'll always try to see you in Britain
because you really can pay a penalty for
saying something that's not so and
libelous can't do that here someone
possibly win a libel suit in the United
States so we are very broad free speech
I mean the right to lie to that you're
through your teeth if you have enough
money to get it out there is an
established right in the United States
Constitution
it's the First Amendment and it's
important it does maintain our democracy
because you don't want people like me
threatening to sue you as a reporter for
writing stuff that I don't happen to
like it does okay so the antidote is not
to limit what they can say the antidote
is to do existence to have this
incredible instrument of democracy at
your fingertips which is the net so you
can avoid them altogether and pay no
attention to them and do a search to
your own in your own mind which will
allow you to figure out what the what's
your version of the truth is what makes
the most sense do I think we should have
a state-sponsored media no I think the
BBC is actually terrific the BBC
maintains and has been maroc is actually
a huge opponent of this to independence
from the government Murdock is going
more than once to the Conservatives
after he's trying to get them in and try
to get them to put the hammer down on
the BBC and it's usually resisted we
have NPR and I know the Conservatives
think it's all liberal bias and all that
maybe it is but it does actually a very
good job and so does Educational
Television all of it most of their stuff
is not that current events are in it
except for maybe a layer and so forth so
I think those models are fine I don't
think you're ever going to have a state
media I don't think we should have a
state media I because I don't think
there's a government version of the
truth and when you have that you have to
enforce the independence and then you
get people like Congress it wants to
pull pull your funding if they don't
agree with you and I think the best
antidote is actually the one your
generation is discovered which is so
much access to your own ability to find
out what you want that it makes the the
organized media meaningless and I think
they're deserve to be meaningless right
about now maybe they'll bend their ways
and put on a program that actually
benefits the country yes dang cover one
of the presidents of where scaredy's
what is your one
and you know teaching you about yourself
or the country uh mostly good things did
taught me some things I don't like about
the media very much but but I will say
this about running for president Gary
Hart once told me that no wimp ever
became president the United States and
that is true you just you mean you know
you go through everything people say the
most outrageous things they print the
most out ready I had reporters
threatened to write stories claiming I
engaged insider trading unless I gave
them this information you know just
outrageous stuff but on the other hand
you know you complain about that then
how are you going to stand up to
Vladimir Putin or achmad in a job right
so I don't think it's so bad this is a
really tough not very pleasant process
to go through I mean this is the largest
nation of the face of the earth in terms
of our barn economy in our military
power if you're going to be the person
who's in charge of that you'd better be
tough so I you know I don't think it's
all that bad i mean it's horrible and
you most normal people would never
submit to it people kept asking me where
you're going to run again I said you
know the first time you do this you
don't know what you're getting into it
is forgivable the second time you had
really better have a session way with
your wife and be with your psychiatrist
because you know you know what's coming
and you've got to think twice about this
but it's it's it is not I mean from an
existential human point of view it's a
terrible process and all that but from
to get to what you need to have me in
the President and I say not such a bad
thing to put everybody through hell
because if they can't stand up to a
campaign you know you the new york times
reporter is a jerk for asking you stuff
that's not so we're putting in the paper
where you see Putin Ahmadinejad that's
that's a real problem yes so given would
be this
education coming there's all that
information access is great different
lack of critical thinking capabilities
it's useless so what do you see coming
from your charge for their other stuff
to make sure you don't just push for
that massage about how to figuratively
and articulate this well that's it
really that's an incredibly complex
question I've trying to try not to take
the rest of the time a bit trying so you
have to have a balance you can't just do
everything with standardized tests for
two reasons first of all you can't
measure creative thinking with
standardized tests and secondly the
great the extraordinary thing about
schools is the hit or miss quality of
schools in the sense that's a downside
to it but it's also an upside great
teachers are really turned on by what
they teach even if it may be quote
unquote irrelevant to everyday
experience well you're not most of you
far enough away from your school
experience maybe some of you are because
I mean you're in an institution like
this I can still remember professors
that I had when I was in college or even
high schools saying things that are
stuck with me for 40 years some of them
had nothing to do with what I do with my
life every day but it was their passion
their love for what they were doing that
made me remember it forever and that's a
life lesson so you don't want to
extinguish that we do have to have
standardized tests you I mean you don't
I don't care what that you do in the
wealthy suburban schools every good but
he's gonna do fine there but I do care
what happens in the inner city schools
because we have done a crappy job for 40
years after the civil rights movement
things have not gotten a whole lot
better in a lot of those schools so
you've got to have standardized tests
not you got to know what nine times nine
does when you get out of school is when
you get out of school that's true
whether you're in Montana or Mississippi
or or Pittsburgh you don't know that
you're probably not going to be able to
make a living and we have an obligation
to get people out of school to know
things like that but that you don't want
to have so much of that that that's all
there is a lot of the problem is
principals school leadership in the
building makes a big difference and we
drive principles into the ground they
spend half their work on politics at
least in my state running around all
these different meetings
all the time and they can't lead there's
enormous numbers of problems in
education I think the best thing to do
frankly is to have different models
appropriate to the different community
and have measurable standards that
everybody's expected to achieve and we
actually are making some progress
towards this but don't and get out of
the it's all the teach school that's
another big thing is maybe the most
important thing I'm going to say the
most important thing about schools is
not what happens in the school is what
happens before anybody ever gets to
school we don't do anything for zero to
three kids head starts wonderful it
doesn't start until your three the
twenty percent of kids who really are in
trouble our kids who come from family
backgrounds that they never had a chance
before they got to school the single
moms you were on have drug problems the
abusive people boyfriend's in the rural
areas where you know nobody if we don't
start investing money in 023 I actually
did a lot of this when I was governor
not because of education but because our
prison system was filling up our person
system is full of kids who never had a
chance they've decided that they schools
wasn't for them by the time they were
the third grade they didn't sit and say
oh I can't wait to get out of here they
just had signed out they knew it wasn't
for them that's our fault that's not the
school systems of this teachers unions
fall we'd not as a society we don't
invest in zero to three and if we do do
start investing in 0 to 3 and start
supporting families and make it easier
for them to raise kids that's going to
make a big difference so there's a lot
of things we need to fundamentally
change I think the 0 to 3 stuff is just
as important as what goes on in the
schools and I do believe that there are
in there are exciting hard-working
people in every single community in the
country that can be empowered with the
right tools and support to do better in
their school systems we have to be more
flexible about there's not a
one-size-fits-all model for every every
one of the however many tens of millions
of kids we have in our school system but
we need standardization but we also need
creativity we can't stress enough out
creativity just for the sake of the
standardized tests but we do have to
have accountability we haven't had
lot of that and mostly we have to be
accountable as a society and stop
pretending the school system can fix all
the problems that we are caused outside
the school system we have to invest
early on there's going to be some time
where we're going to have to do two
generations at not just one that is if a
13 year old has a baby they both need
help not just the baby and until we're
willing to help them both that baby is
never going to have the opportunity ever
I don't know how many of you know
anything about the Harlem Children's
Zone Geoffrey Canada if you ought to
read a book by a guy named Paul tough it
was a reporter for The New York Times I
think it's called what it take whatever
it takes or something like that it's
incredible he didn't get it all right
he's one of the early innovators and
there's plenty of things that mistakes
he made and so forth but he has really
proved that with real emphasis on early
childhood and support a deal is you come
with us when you have that baby and we
don't care what your circumstances are
stick with us do we say will guarantee
your kid goes to college that's the sort
of the compact that we ought to make but
it's not just the school system can do
we got to have a social system that
supports it's very inexpensive to do it
by the way 0 or 3 costs nothing compared
to what it costs to put somebody in
prison per year yes following up on I
think this is the last one the president
is about together
tagging off to 24 hour news questions
and a lot of your answers seem to have
been focused on the younger generation
saying you know they will make it better
we have their access to news outlets and
parrot outlets and better information
but what about the older generation
that's already listening to all this
like how do we get them to listen to
more intelligent programming for example
like Diane Greene without having first
to sensationalistic oh yes i love the
older people are who they are and
they're not going to change so look the
good news is the people who elected
obama last time we're under 35 this time
they're going to be under 39 next time
it's under 43 after that I said you get
the idea here I mean the Tea Party it's
not a coincidence e party is all over 55
and white right this is the shrinking
minority ever shrinking and the shrinker
year they get the matter they get which
is why they've gotten so off the deep
end so you know I mean I don't want to
say all got to do is wait wait out the
change we can't do that but the idea
you're going to suddenly change some
right-wing guy who for his own who can't
keep himself together without saying
that Obama is a socialist you're not
going to do that that's a deep problem
that you can't fix so all you can do is
do what you think is right every day in
your own personal life but also in your
community and these webs of activism and
if a candidate like Obama comes along
that you really think is great you
really do have an obligation get out and
do what you can for that person I
actually don't think you have an
obligation just to be involved in quote
unquote party politics unless you're
interested in it but I do think you have
an obligation to do something very
community every single day sometimes for
four minutes and sometimes I hope for
for four hours and that will it's going
to change I mean I'll just leave you
with this thought you know you guys are
all very young and I'm not so young
anymore and despite the president's kind
remarks so when I was your age I don't
know how old you are but when I was a
freshman in college I had two
african-american roommates that was very
unusual in 1967 when this is a civil
rights era
was that my the spring of that year
Martin Luther King was killed Bobby
Kennedy was killed the riots destroyed
the convention in Chicago isn't quite a
time to be in the middle of all that if
you had asked us whether 40 years from
now we're gonna have a black president
all of us would have told you you were
nuts and 40 years later that you think
40 years is a lot at your age 40 years
in history is a blink of an eye think
how this country has been transformed
for all that and that's why I'd say this
is what I said it to the gay community
but wait a minute now I know you're all
upset because you know we haven't done
much about Don't Ask Don't Tell and all
there's a nine years when Bush came into
office it was one state with equal
rights for everybody including those
with different sexual orientation when
he left office only nine years now
that's that's comprehensible for your
age group right nine years all of a
sudden now nine states the pic chase the
paint pace of changes incredibly fast in
this country it doesn't ever seem fast
when you're 20 and that's a good thing
because we rely on the energy of 20 year
olds who and their impatience to make
things change we can't do that without
that lack of long-term perspective
because you have a long-term perspective
you get to do you like me oh it's all
going to get better you know it's going
to get better because people like you
aren't going to put up with the way it
is but it does get better if you keep at
it and when you stop keeping at it is
when it stops getting better and that
you don't want to do thanks
you